R Hoy os vamos a presentar en VisualPolitik
la historia más 2021 de todo el año 2021.
Atentos: miles de solicitantes de asilo iraquíes
en la frontera de Polonia con Bielorrusia.
Y diréis ¿Pero qué tiene de especial? Pues
vamos a ver… fijaos en el mapa.
Iraq está aquí, Bielorrusia está aquí
y Polonia está aquí. Estáis pensando lo
mismo que yo, ¿no? ¿Qué pintan unos iraquíes
cruzando la frontera entre Bielorrusia y Polonia?
Pues es lo que os vamos a contar en este video.
Lo que tenemos es lo siguiente. Desde el lado
bielorruso, hasta siete mil iraquíes, pero
también sirios, iraníes, afganos, libaneses…
Están en la frontera, y lo que quieren es
entrar en la Unión Europea. ¿Por dónde?
Por los tres países de la UE que tienen la
inmensa suerte de ser vecinos de Bielorrusia.
Hablamos de Polonia, Lituania y Letonia. Como
os podéis imaginar, a ninguno de ellos le
hace gracia ver de repente a toda esta gente
en su frontera. Y, para colmo, no es que estemos
hablando de paz y amor. Atentos:
(La violencia estalla en la frontera entre
Polonia y Bielorrusia cuando los guardias
polacos disparan cañones de agua contra migrantes
que arrojan piedras)
Exacto, una lluvia de piedras por un lado,
cañones de agua y gases lacrimógenos por
el otro, los migrantes intentan tirar abajo
los puestos fronterizos, Polonia refuerza
la frontera, Lituania empieza a construir
un muro, la OTAN se plantea intervenir…
y todo esto se ha desarrollado en menos de
un mes. Vamos, que en los 1200 kilómetros
de frontera entre Bielorrusia y la Unión
Europea se ha concentrado tanta acción que
hasta la última película de James Bond se
queda corta. Y me diréis, vamos a ver, Fonseca,
nos lo estás pintando como una crisis macronachovidaliana,
pero siete mil personas entre tres países
tampoco es para tanto, ¿no? Al fin y al cabo,
en 2015 la UE recibió a más de un millón
de solicitantes de asilo y ahí sigue. Bueno,
decídselo al primer ministro de Polonia.
("Señoras y señores, me dirijo a ustedes
porque Europa -nuestra casa común- está
amenazada)
Como veis, para Polonia, lo que está pasando
en su frontera es una declaración de guerra
en toda regla. Y si hace dos meses el señor
Morawiecki estaba diciendo que la UE le hace
chantaje, aquí lo tenemos apelando a Bruselas
y a los valores comunes. Ahora bien, en cualquier
caso, Polonia no sería la única víctima
de esta historia. Porque en el momento en
el que estamos grabando este vídeo, al menos
trece migrantes han perdido la vida. Recordad
que hablamos también de familias, hablamos
también de niños -incluso recién nacidos-
y sobre todo hablamos del invierno.
(Niño de 14 años 'muere de frío' en la
frontera de Bielorrusia mientras los migrantes
están siendo usados como ‘armas’ en una
crisis cada vez mayor)
Y la pregunta que os estaríais haciendo es,
uno: ¿usados como armas por quién? ¿Quién
es el malo malísimo de esta historia, el
genio del mal detrás de todo esto? Dos: ¿qué
narices pintan unos iraquíes cruzando la
frontera entre Polonia y Bielorrusia? Tres,
y ¿dónde están ahora? ¿Cuál ha sido el
desenlace de todo esto? ¿Ha sido una de estas
historias de las que mañana ni nos acordaremos,
o de verdad nos deberíamos preocupar? Hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas, pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
(EL HOMBRE QUE QUERÍA SER SUPERVILLANO)
Ya sé lo que estaréis pensando algunos:
seguro que Rusia tiene que estar aquí metida.
Porque claro, hablamos de Bielo-Rusia, ese
país que normalmente por sí solo tampoco
es que mueva los hilos de la política internacional.
Y, efectivamente, hay gente que dice que todo
lo que está pasando ahora en la frontera
bielorrusa es parte del gran plan de Putin
para desestabilizar Europa, hacer que Rusia
sea grande de nuevo y dominar el mundo.
Pero lo cierto es que, al menos, técnicamente,
no tiene mucho sentido que esta crisis bielorrusa
se esté orquestando desde Moscú. Es más,
no sería la primera vez que Bielorrusia se
impone a los intereses de su gran hermano
ruso.
Aquí lo que tiene pinta es que se basta solo
el señor Lukashenko. ¿Y quién es Lukashenko?
Para los que seáis nuevos en VisualPolitik
y todavía no os hayáis visto todos los vídeos
que hemos hecho sobre Bielorrusia, os voy
a hacer un spoiler: Bielorrusia es una dictadura.
Es más, es la última gran dictadura de Europa.
Y, además, no lo intenta disimular en absoluto,
sino que hace todo lo contrario. Si algún
día se inventa el “día del orgullo dictador”,
Lukashenko será la reina de la cabalgata.
Atentos.
(Es mejor ser un dictador que gay, declara
el presidente de Bielorrusia)
Sí, habéis oído bien. Os presento a Aleksandr
Lukashenko. Algunos niños querían ser astronautas,
o YouTubers. Él quería ser dictador.
A veces me tengo envidia a mí mismo, soy
el último y el único dictador de Europa.
Tal cual como lo oís. Os lo voy a decir aun
más claro: Aleksandr Lukashenko es un señor
que quería ser supervillano.
Y dentro de lo que cabe, no le ha salido mal:
ha llegado a ser el dictador de un país de
nueve millones de habitantes. Llegó al poder
hace ya 27 años, y le ha gustado tanto que
ha decidido quedarse, a ser posible, para
siempre.
Y claro, como hay una parte cada vez más
grande de la población que no está conforme
con vivir en una dictadura, en los últimos
años el régimen bielorruso se ha ido cerrando
progresivamente.
Primero, prohibiendo las protestas, con multas,
detenciones, cargas policiales y represiones
varias. Segundo, restringiendo la libertad
de prensa. A día de hoy, hay varios medios
que o bien se han tenido que cerrar, o bien
a los que no se puede acceder desde Bielorrusia.
Hablamos de una ofensiva en toda regla:
(Periodistas bielorrusos condenados a dos
años de cárcel por transmitir las protestas
en directo)
(Tut.by, un sitio de noticias leído por más
del 40% de los usuarios de Internet bielorrusos,
ha sido bloqueado y sus editores interrogados
después de una redada en sus oficinas y casas)
Con todo esto, no os debería sorprender que
Bielorrusia sea el país con menos libertad
de prensa en toda Europa. Sí, incluso le
va peor que a Turquía. Y ya os podéis imaginar
cómo funciona la política en este país.
P Para no ir más lejos, las últimas elecciones
presidenciales se celebraron en agosto del
año pasado. En un principio, la cosa pintaba
sorprendentemente bien: obviamente, Lukashenko
era el candidato principal, pero en la papeleta
provisional también había varios nombres
de la oposición que tenían apoyo popular.
Y hasta había analistas que decían: mira,
a lo mejor es el momento para que haya una
transición, un nuevo presidente y quizás
hasta un poquitín de democracia.
Si seguís VisualPolitik desde hace tiempo,
ya sabéis lo que ocurrió porque le dedicamos
un vídeo en su momento. Por cierto, que este
es un momento fantástico para recordaros
que os suscribáis a este canal y que echéis
un vistazo a nuestro Patreon.
Si nos apoyáis en Patreon, no sólo estaréis
colaborando con este proyecto. Además, recibiréis
acceso a nuestra newsletter semanal donde
os mandamos análisis de política internacional
que no encontraréis en ningún otro medio.
Cosas como las protestas de Cuba, la inflación
en Estados Unidos o las últimas noticias
de Corea del Norte. Vamos, que si queréis
estar bien informados, el Patreon de VisualPolitik
es el resumen semanal perfecto. Y además,
estaréis ayudando a hacer crecer esta comunidad.
Vamos, que es el dos por uno.
Pero volvamos a nuestra historia de hoy. Por
si no recordáis lo que ocurrió en las últimas
elecciones Bielorrusas, aquí tenéis un resumen
en 3 noticias.
(Bielorrusia prohíbe a dos candidatos de
la oposición presentarse a las elecciones)
(Representantes de la oposición bielorrusa
detenidos antes de las elecciones presidenciales)
(Elecciones en Bielorrusia: la líder de la
oposición Tikhanovskaya se fue 'por el bien
de sus hijos')
Como os podéis imaginar, cuando llegó el
día de las elecciones, ni las protestas ni
la presión internacional han valido para
garantizar un nivel mínimo de transparencia.
Y con eso, Lukashenko empezó su sexto mandato
siendo más dictador que nunca.
Para que nos entendamos, a día de hoy, en
las cárceles bielorrusas hay hasta 800 presos
políticos. Y nadie se queda a salvo, porque
el régimen de Lukashenko tiene brazos muy
largos. Atentos a una de las noticias más
surrealistas de este año:
(Un vuelo de Ryanair con un periodista de
la oposición se ve obligado a aterrizar en
Bielorrusia)
Habéis oído bien: bajo una amenaza de bomba
falsa, Bielorrusia secuestró un avión de
Ryanair que estaba volando de Grecia a Lituania,
solo para bajar a un periodista opositor y
llevárselo a la cárcel.
Sí, ¡un avión de Ryanair! Así que, ya
sabéis, la próxima vez que voléis con una
compañía low-cost, nada de quejaros de si
el asiento no es cómodo, o si no os dejan
subir la maleta. ¡Dad las gracias de que
no os haya secuestrado Bielorrusia! Vamos,
si solo por eso Lukashenko no se merece un
premio de supervillano del año, ya no sé
que más deciros. O, bueno, sí. ¿Cuál es
este plan maléfico definitivo, la estrategia
nominada a “idas de olla dictatoriales 2021”?
Ahora mismo, lo vamos a ver.
(IBA PARA LISTO Y SE QUEDÓ EN LISTILLO)
Antes de hablar de esta idea del siglo, os
tengo que decir una cosa. Obviamente, las
artimañas de Lukashenko no solo tienen impacto
en Bielorrusia. Pensad, de nuevo, en aquR
Hoy os vamos a presentar en VisualPolitik
la historia más 2021 de todo el año 2021.
Atentos: miles de solicitantes de asilo iraquíes
en la frontera de Polonia con Bielorrusia.
Y diréis ¿Pero qué tiene de especial? Pues
vamos a ver… fijaos en el mapa.
Iraq está aquí, Bielorrusia está aquí
y Polonia está aquí. Estáis pensando lo
mismo que yo, ¿no? ¿Qué pintan unos iraquíes
cruzando la frontera entre Bielorrusia y Polonia?
Pues es lo que os vamos a contar en este video.
Lo que tenemos es lo siguiente. Desde el lado
bielorruso, hasta siete mil iraquíes, pero
también sirios, iraníes, afganos, libaneses…
Están en la frontera, y lo que quieren es
entrar en la Unión Europea. ¿Por dónde?
Por los tres países de la UE que tienen la
inmensa suerte de ser vecinos de Bielorrusia.
Hablamos de Polonia, Lituania y Letonia. Como
os podéis imaginar, a ninguno de ellos le
hace gracia ver de repente a toda esta gente
en su frontera. Y, para colmo, no es que estemos
hablando de paz y amor. Atentos:
(La violencia estalla en la frontera entre
Polonia y Bielorrusia cuando los guardias
polacos disparan cañones de agua contra migrantes
que arrojan piedras)
Exacto, una lluvia de piedras por un lado,
cañones de agua y gases lacrimógenos por
el otro, los migrantes intentan tirar abajo
los puestos fronterizos, Polonia refuerza
la frontera, Lituania empieza a construir
un muro, la OTAN se plantea intervenir…
y todo esto se ha desarrollado en menos de
un mes. Vamos, que en los 1200 kilómetros
de frontera entre Bielorrusia y la Unión
Europea se ha concentrado tanta acción que
hasta la última película de James Bond se
queda corta. Y me diréis, vamos a ver, Fonseca,
nos lo estás pintando como una crisis macronachovidaliana,
pero siete mil personas entre tres países
tampoco es para tanto, ¿no? Al fin y al cabo,
en 2015 la UE recibió a más de un millón
de solicitantes de asilo y ahí sigue. Bueno,
decídselo al primer ministro de Polonia.
("Señoras y señores, me dirijo a ustedes
porque Europa -nuestra casa común- está
amenazada)
Como veis, para Polonia, lo que está pasando
en su frontera es una declaración de guerra
en toda regla. Y si hace dos meses el señor
Morawiecki estaba diciendo que la UE le hace
chantaje, aquí lo tenemos apelando a Bruselas
y a los valores comunes. Ahora bien, en cualquier
caso, Polonia no sería la única víctima
de esta historia. Porque en el momento en
el que estamos grabando este vídeo, al menos
trece migrantes han perdido la vida. Recordad
que hablamos también de familias, hablamos
también de niños -incluso recién nacidos-
y sobre todo hablamos del invierno.
(Niño de 14 años 'muere de frío' en la
frontera de Bielorrusia mientras los migrantes
están siendo usados como ‘armas’ en una
crisis cada vez mayor)
Y la pregunta que os estaríais haciendo es,
uno: ¿usados como armas por quién? ¿Quién
es el malo malísimo de esta historia, el
genio del mal detrás de todo esto? Dos: ¿qué
narices pintan unos iraquíes cruzando la
frontera entre Polonia y Bielorrusia? Tres,
y ¿dónde están ahora? ¿Cuál ha sido el
desenlace de todo esto? ¿Ha sido una de estas
historias de las que mañana ni nos acordaremos,
o de verdad nos deberíamos preocupar? Hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas, pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
(EL HOMBRE QUE QUERÍA SER SUPERVILLANO)
Ya sé lo que estaréis pensando algunos:
seguro que Rusia tiene que estar aquí metida.
Porque claro, hablamos de Bielo-Rusia, ese
país que normalmente por sí solo tampoco
es que mueva los hilos de la política internacional.
Y, efectivamente, hay gente que dice que todo
lo que está pasando ahora en la frontera
bielorrusa es parte del gran plan de Putin
para desestabilizar Europa, hacer que Rusia
sea grande de nuevo y dominar el mundo.
Pero lo cierto es que, al menos, técnicamente,
no tiene mucho sentido que esta crisis bielorrusa
se esté orquestando desde Moscú. Es más,
no sería la primera vez que Bielorrusia se
impone a los intereses de su gran hermano
ruso.
Aquí lo que tiene pinta es que se basta solo
el señor Lukashenko. ¿Y quién es Lukashenko?
Para los que seáis nuevos en VisualPolitik
y todavía no os hayáis visto todos los vídeos
que hemos hecho sobre Bielorrusia, os voy
a hacer un spoiler: Bielorrusia es una dictadura.
Es más, es la última gran dictadura de Europa.
Y, además, no lo intenta disimular en absoluto,
sino que hace todo lo contrario. Si algún
día se inventa el “día del orgullo dictador”,
Lukashenko será la reina de la cabalgata.
Atentos.
(Es mejor ser un dictador que gay, declara
el presidente de Bielorrusia)
Sí, habéis oído bien. Os presento a Aleksandr
Lukashenko. Algunos niños querían ser astronautas,
o YouTubers. Él quería ser dictador.
A veces me tengo envidia a mí mismo, soy
el último y el único dictador de Europa.
Tal cual como lo oís. Os lo voy a decir aun
más claro: Aleksandr Lukashenko es un señor
que quería ser supervillano.
Y dentro de lo que cabe, no le ha salido mal:
ha llegado a ser el dictador de un país de
nueve millones de habitantes. Llegó al poder
hace ya 27 años, y le ha gustado tanto que
ha decidido quedarse, a ser posible, para
siempre.
Y claro, como hay una parte cada vez más
grande de la población que no está conforme
con vivir en una dictadura, en los últimos
años el régimen bielorruso se ha ido cerrando
progresivamente.
Primero, prohibiendo las protestas, con multas,
detenciones, cargas policiales y represiones
varias. Segundo, restringiendo la libertad
de prensa. A día de hoy, hay varios medios
que o bien se han tenido que cerrar, o bien
a los que no se puede acceder desde Bielorrusia.
Hablamos de una ofensiva en toda regla:
(Periodistas bielorrusos condenados a dos
años de cárcel por transmitir las protestas
en directo)
(Tut.by, un sitio de noticias leído por más
del 40% de los usuarios de Internet bielorrusos,
ha sido bloqueado y sus editores interrogados
después de una redada en sus oficinas y casas)
Con todo esto, no os debería sorprender que
Bielorrusia sea el país con menos libertad
de prensa en toda Europa. Sí, incluso le
va peor que a Turquía. Y ya os podéis imaginar
cómo funciona la política en este país.
P Para no ir más lejos, las últimas elecciones
presidenciales se celebraron en agosto del
año pasado. En un principio, la cosa pintaba
sorprendentemente bien: obviamente, Lukashenko
era el candidato principal, pero en la papeleta
provisional también había varios nombres
de la oposición que tenían apoyo popular.
Y hasta había analistas que decían: mira,
a lo mejor es el momento para que haya una
transición, un nuevo presidente y quizás
hasta un poquitín de democracia.
Si seguís VisualPolitik desde hace tiempo,
ya sabéis lo que ocurrió porque le dedicamos
un vídeo en su momento. Por cierto, que este
es un momento fantástico para recordaros
que os suscribáis a este canal y que echéis
un vistazo a nuestro Patreon. Si nos apoyáis
en Patreon, no sólo estaréis colaborando
con este proyecto. Además, recibiréis acceso
a nuestra newsletter semanal donde os mandamos
análisis de política internacional que no
encontraréis en ningún otro medio.
Cosas como las protestas de Cuba, la inflación
en Estados Unidos o las últimas noticias
de Corea del Norte. Vamos, que si queréis
estar bien informados, el Patreon de VisualPolitik
es el resumen semanal perfecto. Y además,
estaréis ayudando a hacer crecer esta comunidad.
Vamos, que es el dos por uno.
Pero volvamos a nuestra historia de hoy. Por
si no recordáis lo que ocurrió en las últimas
elecciones Bielorrusas, aquí tenéis un resumen
en 3 noticias.
(Bielorrusia prohíbe a dos candidatos de
la oposición presentarse a las elecciones)
(Representantes de la oposición bielorrusa
detenidos antes de las elecciones presidenciales)
(Elecciones en Bielorrusia: la líder de la
oposición Tikhanovskaya se fue 'por el bien
de sus hijos')
Como os podéis imaginar, cuando llegó el
día de las elecciones, ni las protestas ni
la presión internacional han valido para
garantizar un nivel mínimo de transparencia.
Y con eso, Lukashenko empezó su sexto mandato
siendo más dictador que nunca.
Para que nos entendamos, a día de hoy, en
las cárceles bielorrusas hay hasta 800 presos
políticos. Y nadie se queda a salvo, porque
el régimen de Lukashenko tiene brazos muy
largos. Atentos a una de las noticias más
surrealistas de este año:
(Un vuelo de Ryanair con un periodista de
la oposición se ve obligado a aterrizar en
Bielorrusia)
Habéis oído bien: bajo una amenaza de bomba
falsa, Bielorrusia secuestró un avión de
Ryanair que estaba volando de Grecia a Lituania,
solo para bajar a un periodista opositor y
llevárselo a la cárcel.
Sí, ¡un avión de Ryanair! Así que, ya
sabéis, la próxima vez que voléis con una
compañía low-cost, nada de quejaros de si
el asiento no es cómodo, o si no os dejan
subir la maleta. ¡Dad las gracias de que
no os haya secuestrado Bielorrusia! Vamos,
si solo por eso Lukashenko no se merece un
premio de supervillano del año, ya no sé
que más deciros. O, bueno, sí. ¿Cuál es
este plan maléfico definitivo, la estrategia
nominada a “idas de olla dictatoriales 2021”?
Ahora mismo, lo vamos a ver.
(IBA PARA LISTO Y SE QUEDÓ EN LISTILLO)
Antes de hablar de esta idea del siglo, os
tengo que decir una cosa. Obviamente, las
artimañas de Lukashenko no solo tienen impacto
en Bielorrusia. Pensad, de nuevo, en aquel
vuelo de Ryanair: hasta mayo de este año,
nadie se pensaba que un país, por muy dictadura
que sea, podría secuestrar así un avión
comercial que sobrevuela su espacio aéreo.
Claro está que la Unión Europea y otros
no se quedan de brazos cruzados. Lo que hacen
es imponer sanciones y otras medidas por el
estilo. Hablamos, por ejemplo, de un embargo
de armas y otros bienes que podrían usarse
para la represión. Pero sobre todo hablamos
de sanciones con nombre y apellido, contra
166 representantes del régimen. Sus activos
están congelados, y no pueden viajar a la
UE o transitar por ella. Obviamente, el propio
Aleksandr Lukashenko es uno de estos sancionados,
y además la UE no reconoce su gobierno.
Bueno, creo que ya os podéis imaginar cómo
es la dinámica: Bielorrusia da un pasito
más hacia una dictadura perfecta, la UE responde
con un paquete de sanciones. Bielorrusia reprime
a periodistas, otro paquete de sanciones.
Falsifica elecciones, otro. Secuestra un avión,
más sanciones. Y aquí tenemos al señor
Lukashenko sufriendo con el quiero y no puedo.
Si pensáis que ser un dictador es fácil,
os equivocáis.
Por un lado, quiere tener la última palabra
porque necesita proyectar una imagen fuerte,
tanto de cara a la población que todavía
le apoya como hacia el exterior. Por el otro,
decidme, ¿qué puede hacer Bielorrusia contra
la UE? Y es entonces, cuando este hombre en
su afán de ser un genio del mal dijo: vale,
¿cómo puedo yo atacar a la UE para vengarme
un poco de esas sanciones comerciales y, a
ser posible, obligarles a sentarse en la mesa
conmigo y reconocerme como presidente? ¿Puedo
atacarles con mi ejército? Evidentemente
no. ¿Puedo mandarles terroristas? No. ¿Puedo
hacer una guerra comercial como ha hecho Putin
alguna vez con el gas natural? No. Bueno,
ya nos estamos acercando al punto álgido
de este proceso mental. No sé si es que Lukashenko
se ha visto Gambito de Dama y se ha creído
un estratega, o si es que se lo ha soñado.
Pero esto que vais a ver ahora ha ocurrido
en la vida real. Atentos:
(El dictador de Bielorrusia amenaza con "inundar
la Unión Europea con drogas y migrantes")
¿¡Pero, por favor!? ¿No os parece una idea
de supervillano de película? Porque, además,
sé que parece difícil, pero es que cuando
a Lukashenko se le antoja algo, nada es imposible.
Atentos a la jugada. Paso uno: para organizar
una crisis migratoria, lo mínimo que necesitas
son los propios migrantes, ¿no? Y si no los
tienes a mano, te los tienes que traer. ¿Cómo?
Organizando toda una campaña de publicidad
en los países en los que la gente tiene muchas
razones para querer marcharse: Iraq, Siria,
Líbano, Afganistán y otras zonas calientes.
Para convencerles, basta con promesas como
esta:
(La información falsa difundida a menudo
en el pasado incluía que "cada refugiado
recibe un pago de bienvenida de 2.000 euros".)
Una paga de bienvenida en Alemania, un trabajo
garantizado en la UE… Son algunas de las
promesas que están detrás de esta crisis
migratoria. Paso dos, vamos con la logística:
¿cómo traemos a toda esta gente a las puertas
de la UE? Pues muy fácil, emitiendo visados
turísticos bielorrusos como si no hubiera
mañana. Una vez los tengamos, colocamos a
estos “turistas” en aviones irlandeses
operados por una compañía aérea bielorrusa.
Cuando lleguen a Bielorrusia, los traemos
a la frontera y les decimos por dónde tienen
que ir para cruzar la frontera con Polonia
y llegar a Alemania. Et voilà, el truco de
magia de sacarse de la manga una crisis migratoria
ya está hecho. Y me vais a preguntar: ¿tenemos
certezas de que Bielorrusia esté ayudando
a los migrantes a llegar a la frontera? Bueno,
veréis:
(VIDEO: 00:00-00:07) ¿Nuestros chicos les
están ayudando a los migrantes a llegar al
territorio de Polonia? Es perfectamente posible.
Creo que es absolutamente posible.)
Vamos, repetid con el señor Lukashenko: disimular
es de débiles. Ahora que ya sabéis en qué
consiste este plan maestro, decidme: ¿qué
podía salir mal? Pues es lo que vamos a ver
ahora mismo.
(LA NUEVA GUERRA HÍBRIDA)
Claro, a lo mejor Lukashenko estaba convencido
de que Bruselas insistiría en aceptar y repartir
a los migrantes y solicitantes de asilo, Polonia
se opondría, como ya lo hizo en 2016, y que,
con esto, los bloques este y oeste de la Unión
Europea entrarían en una guerra civil a muerte.
Pero la verdad es que la UE se ha mostrado
bastante más cohesionada de lo que Lukashenko
se esperaba. La Comisión Europea ha destinado
700.000 euros a la ayuda humanitaria y la
Cruz Roja está operando en la zona.
Polonia y Lituania están reforzando las fronteras,
hay mucho margen de mejora, pero, al menos
de momento, la situación se está desescalando.
Y esto es así porque lo primero que ha hecho
la UE fue cortar el grifo migratorio. Por
una parte, hablaron con los países de origen
y de tránsito, presionando por ejemplo con
quitarles la ayuda al desarrollo. Y, por otra
parte, presionaron también a las compañías
aéreas amenazándoles con sanciones. Como
resultado, países de tránsito como Uzbekistán,
Turquía o Emiratos Árabes Unidos empezaron
a restringir los vuelos a Bielorrusia. Y,
además, el gobierno de Iraq ha puesto aviones
para empezar a traer a su gente de vuelta.
(Cientos de migrantes regresan a Irak en un
vuelo desde Bielorrusia)
Y os preguntaréis: y ya está, ¿no? ¿Es
una historia muy concreta que ha ocurrido
en Bielorrusia, y no tiene ninguna repercusión
para el resto del mundo? Pues por sorprendente
que parezca, esto de utilizar migrantes y
solicitantes de asilo como arma política
no es la primera vez que ocurre.
Lo hemos visto con Turquía en 2015 y más
recientemente con Marruecos. Turquía estaba
en el camino de una de las principales rutas
migratorias después de la guerra de Siria,
y precisamente por eso pudo imponer sus condiciones
en el acuerdo migratorio de 2016. Básicamente,
Ankara recibía fondos europeos a cambio de
controlar el acceso de migrantes y solicitantes
de asilo a la UE.
Hoy, sigue siendo un gatekeeper clave, así
que le guste o no, Bruselas tiene que contar
con Erdogan. Y este año, en España hemos
visto una crisis migratoria organizada por
Marruecos, otro país que actúa de filtro
migratorio para Europa. Después de que un
líder saharaui fuese hospitalizado en Logroño
—qué coincidencia— miles de migrantes
empezaron a llegar de repente a Ceuta.
Como veis, los migrantes y solicitantes de
asilo sí se usan para hacer presión en la
política internacional. Y vale, Bielorrusia
también es un país que tiene frontera con
la UE. Pero a diferencia de Turquía y Marruecos,
Bielorrusia no está en el medio de un flujo
migratorio. Si en algo coinciden el primer
ministro polaco y Úrsula Von Der Leyen es
en que lo de Lukashenko es un intento de orquestar
una guerra híbrida con una crisis migratoria
completamente artificial. Y la pregunta es:
¿le ha merecido la pena? Pues lo cierto es
que no. Vale, que ha conseguido llamar la
atención de todo el mundo. Incluso ha hablado
dos veces con Ángela Merkel. Pero aquí se
acaban las ventajas. Porque, además, a ver
qué hace con los migrantes que no llegan
a Polonia, pero tampoco vuelven a Iraq. Si
se quedan en Minsk, es muy probable que Lukashenko
se “inunde” a sí mismo con todos esos
solicitantes de asilo.
Evidentemente, esto no tiene por qué ser
necesariamente malo para Bielorrusia, pero
sí puede traerle problemas políticos. Pensad
que, a diferencia de Europa, Bielorrusia no
tiene recursos suficientes para integrar a
todos esos migrantes. Tampoco tienen un mercado
de trabajo que les pueda absorber. Veremos
cómo se desarrollan los acontecimientos en
los próximos meses. Pero todo apunta a que
Lukashenko quiso ser un supervillano de película
del 007 y se ha quedado a la altura de un
Doctor Maligno.
Pero ahora, la pregunta es para vosotros:
¿qué os ha parecido el plan de Lukashenko?
¿Conocéis más casos en los que los migrantes
sean utilizados como armas? Y, ¿cómo actuaríais
en este caso si fueseis Bruselas? Podéis
dejar vuestras respuestas en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí, en VisualPolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así
que suscribíos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado este vídeo,
dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el próximo. Un
abrazo y hasta pronto.